and in recent weeks there has been a
drastic decrease in the number of
cob vaccines and 19 administered
in the us so that me projection wixson to
javier time we would be the white house is
now not so sure that the country will
reach the goal set  by the
president to administer at least one
dose of the COB vaccine and 19 to
70% of eligible Americans this
despite the fact that the vaccine is now already
approved for adolescents older
than 12 years are currently
being administered nationally  about one
million doses of the vaccine each day
compared to April when
more than 3 million doses were being administered
daily the
largest decrease in vaccines administered has
been seen in the southern states of the country
the government is now  is focusing on
working with churches and
community centers to distribute the vaccine
in hopes of reaching the
president's goal the country may still
reach  that goal nationally but it
is unlikely that
all singles will reach that number and
that is causing concerns that
there will be new outbreaks of kobe 19
especially now that summer is approaching
and more people will start
traveling reporting in washington
alexandra limon